[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and
horror movies just don't work when
you've got a walter
this fall
[Music]
six cities
prepare
for two
rebels with a cause
[Music]
phoenix
houston
charleston nashville new york
baltimore
the rebels with a cause comedy tour
tickets on sale now at
louderwithcrowder.com
tour
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
channel
[Music]
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
ah
that's called not a sip i realize that
this shirt was un unbuttoned because
usually i leave the top button
unbuttoned but i don't usually wear a
fat guy hawaiian shirt nice shirt
yeah but thank you for that gerald
thank you we'll circle back to that
on shirts uh so glad to be with you guys
uh today i am i am uh i'm feeling better
the only thing that's gone to my ears
gone to my ear so i can't hear very well
so today i'm going
what huh
do you have an old horn
i have a golden horn from warner
brothers
like grandpa kong yeah playing his old
radio crank what
um
look florida there's a lot going on in
florida i don't know if you know this uh
there might be some monkey pox surprise
miami but desantis is kicking ass and
taking names so we have a few clips
there that we want to uh not only show
you because he's making a major
announcement he says it's a major award
here today and then sweden and finland i
i talked about this
few weeks ago
that i don't think they should join nato
or be allowed to join nato now they are
yeah i gave you five reasons why that's
uh why that's some [ __ ] i just i
just i also let me okay can i just can i
yeah
am i allowed to say this i hate sweden
i hate sweden and with the chinese you
know i always say the chinese government
because i love the chinese people with
sweden i hate all of i hate the people
i hate the country i hate what they
stand for i hate the history
and i would like to see you be uh
whatever the equivalent to the 51st
state of russia would be for you guys
i've never seen their assembled
furniture
yeah i fought over it right
it's just over that mountain [ __ ]
[Laughter]
name that movie reference that's a
that's a theme song by the way uh was
similar to jurassic park okay
so my question for you too we took this
a while back uh i want to see if it's
changed
who would you like to do would you like
to see desantis be the nominee in 2024
or donald trump because it does seem
like it's going to come to blows
and uh i just hope that neither one of
them has to limp into the general uh
considering uh how rough these primaries
can be so uh before we get into that and
more uh gerald how are you i am well how
are you sir i'm okay i just can't hear
very well and uh you know him you love
him we're going to be on tour
louderworthcrowder.com tour big fall
tour the rebels with a cause tour big
theaters phoenix arizona september 16th
houston on september 17th
and then we have a bunch of other dates
after that uh triple ahoy yes how are
you good i'm good man i i can are you
feeling better i feel better
yeah thank god well i'm not the best but
i'm glad you're feeling better because
i've got an anti-cure for all that ails
you ooh right now uh we're about to
watch uh
but a true i should say true hero
do you know what that means you guys
know what that means right yes yeah
means someone we could do without
a teacher what would we do without
public school teachers what we did since
always
wait
you think the hutu tribesmen have public
school teachers
they'd be stringing them up with sunu
the inuit would be stringing them up
with musk ox horns okay so
i've been watching a lot of alone that's
why i know
this is the outfit of a man with very
little left and heart disease
i feel fatter
just wearing this shirt i look comfy i
am oh my god i get relaxed i
i i feel relaxed well the show's it's a
slow news day but oh my god nobody wears
that and is angry it's true yeah yeah it
feels good i mean if i saw someone angry
in this shirt
i'd have some follow-ups it'd be like
because somebody spilled something on it
right yeah exactly
yeah and you know it would be that
person themselves because people wear
these are lazy slobs blaming the
waitress on the daiquiri that they
ordered hey you went to dinner with guy
fieri too no
teachers
are pushing
more wokeness on students my flame shirt
my flame shirt has bacon on it wow
and a quail
why do you have restaurants guy fieri
the worst thing is here's the worst
thing about guy fury he knows his stuff
he knows his stuff yeah he just sells
crap yeah he knows it he's like but i'll
go with hot dogs
i'll make millions he's a michelin chef
and he's selling eggos and pogos
what is wrong with her hot dog eggo
sandwich
you know you know what this half dog
ain't gonna say when she's funnel kick
all right
so this teacher
you can comment below whatever you want
hit like if you're okay with this if not
i don't care it's one of those days it's
gonna be a fun one uh this teacher uh
without a hint of irony i don't know
i'm hoping that the outcome is what she
suspects here
um so this teacher has a student uh i
guess a middle schooler
who schooled her on pronouns and of
course this teacher have you seen these
ads now tick-tock taught me yeah all
over tv tick-tock taught me these are
the new commercials
that's a scary thought very so she goes
to tick-tock to ask you for the answer
because she's not quite clear on whether
her student is smarter than her dumb
woke
sorry useless ass
okay tick-tock i really need your help
here on this one i'm a teacher i teach
fifth and sixth grade and uh this
morning i don't know it's a teacher
announcing it the concept of pronouns
came up um and
one of my students said well miss o'dell
did you even ask me my pronouns and i
was like whoa
i hadn't actually asked him his pronouns
and i had called him and i
said oh i'm so sorry i haven't actually
called you i mean asked you what your
pronouns are and um
what are they he said
i'm sorry banana said banana and rock
and i was like
no like
don't mess around i was i was actually
really upset because you're a woman i
thought he was making fun of it and in
fact i'm still pretty sure he was making
fun of it
and um but they all agreed no like you
can choose anything banana rock if you
want banana and rock to be a pronoun
banana rocks your pronoun
is it tick-tock tell me
i love how all it took was a conclave of
students and the teacher is convinced
that she's dumber than them and she's
right yeah she's like well i can't argue
with that they always wanted to play
rock band pronoun
[Laughter]
what a stupid yeah i'd be like i would
all right i'll tell you what define
pronoun and then i'll call you whatever
you want exactly sit down maybe like
that film with uh kevin kline what was
it with the all boys school i can't
remember what it was called oh yeah oh
dead presidents society dead society
except instead of all dropping a book
it's just dildos oh geez oh she's acting
in my captain
oh farmer captain oh my god oh banana my
rock
i don't know if he was joking or dear
god i hope that kid came home and spoke
with his dad and he said all right look
here's what you do
and he said no i'm gonna get in trouble
he's like your teacher's too dumb for
that you're not gonna get in trouble son
imagine looking at a teacher and going
look uh call me banana rock yeah and
they're like okay i hope you're not
kidding yeah and you're like
absolutely not yeah
100 banana you should go yeah you need
to sit down mister whatever yeah you
should be
what was her like how was she convinced
was her student denzel
yeah yeah you call me banana bro okay
okay we didn't land but you don't want
to call me banana right you don't want
to call me banana right no okay
my friends call me an interrupt but
you're not a friend you're not a friend
you're not a friend no you are not a
friend
i am banana rock tea all right and then
i took to tick tock to lose my job yes
to prove that i'm an idiot removing all
doubt sorry you mispronounced tenure
yeah hey really quickly so the ron
desantis thing i don't know if it's
still going on uh
token one i don't know if you have
anything on that but there was uh his
announcement is concerning i believe law
enforcement so do we have anything on
that yeah uh he just gave the mic over
to a sheriff in tampa that's live right
now it's live right now okay well you
know what we have a story set up for but
let's go right now live to and by the
way hit the like button share if you
like the fact this is live and sometimes
we go off book we're really curious to
see what it is that uh ronda sanchez is
doing major announcement let's see the
decisions for the courts or a jury of
our peers
one of the more egregious examples
occurred in september and involved the
suspension of state attorneys after
shooting someone and then opened fires
on a residence where that victim sought
refuge and protection
inside of that house was the victim his
mother other children and the control
room against everything
who were forced to take cover and hide
to make things even worse nearby was
another mother and her twin infant
twins her twin infant children in a
vehicle
one of the shooters our suspect was
identified and arrested just a short few
days later
after being released from jail he was
caught and arrested for committing
another burglary and while in jail the
state attorney's office no files charges
on the shooting and the separate
burglary charge
right so bring that down this guy's
nervous by the way i love this is the
thing rhonda santos actually works with
real people you can hear how dry his
mouth is yeah you can hear how nervous
he is guy guy can't be blamed for that
no it's just a guy stepping up doing the
right thing so uh okay so basically
what's going on right now is progressive
prosecutors that are supposed to be
backed by george soros that are not
enforcing the law right that's what ron
desantis is addressing basically saying
it's a dereliction of his duty um and
one of the reasons that crime is surging
and that's why they're removing him from
office forcibly removing terrorist
person so i guess state attorney andrew
warren can derelict
my boss
yes
yes
that really hurt when he told me to dare
look at both well no but that's
fantastic i mean you see that happening
everywhere in these of course democratic
cities the the mayor of new york was
actually talking about it 10 guys like
there were 500 crimes committed by 10
people that just kept getting released
let's go back to more of it you guys
give me more on it's andrew warren right
andrew warren andrew warren uh let's see
what he has because we have the preface
to this which took place yesterday so
we'll kind of be doing this a little bit
sort of delorean style going back and
forth i really want to hear what this
guy's to say i'm liking this guy even
though he's nervous turned to that home
even in the face of this adversity law
enforcement continues to report for duty
and uphold their obligation
as your sheriff
i continue to work with my law
enforcement counterparts
who privately
are frustrated with the state attorney
who seems intently focused
on empathy for criminals
and less interested in pursuing justice
for crime victims
as most everyone knows i'm a tremendous
proponent of reducing recidivism i've
created several diversion programs and
continue to provide resources education
and training opportunities for
individuals to rehabilitate and improve
themselves hopefully they've reversed
pedophiles
offenders responsible for their actions
these efforts do not involve a blatant
refusal to uphold the laws of our state
as the governor just outlined and as
tampa law enforcement has seen over the
years
empowering criminals through a lack of
prosecution jeopardizes the safety of
our tampa bay community and makes them
even more brazen to commit additional
crimes and continue to victimize the
innocent
real quick i want to say something a
couple of things here uh i don't have
this uh sheriff's name i would love to
get him his name like the guy uh from
what i'm saying that's for i don't know
everything about him compare what he is
saying right now i guarantee you
call me to the mat on this sheriff chad
chronister by the way his name is chad
perfect so call me to the mat on this if
i am wrong i'm making a prediction here
the left is going to say just like with
the disney situation in florida and ron
desantis this is fascism the right
doesn't care when they're using the law
as their own political or here's the
difference the census has come back up
okay let's let's see desantis
another one of our great sheriffs that
many of you know hulk county sheriff
grady judd
we just did a vanna white thank you very
much
it looks a little bit like mr mackey but
i'm gonna hold that against him and i
can tell you i've done this job my
entire adult life
senior i remember governor when the
felons owned florida
it was in the 70s and 80s
it was called detroit yes i was one of
the cops on the streets
cocaine cowboy
we couldn't keep the criminals locked up
and they preyed on the community and
governor they didn't prey on the ones
behind the gated communities in the
million and half million dollar homes
they prayed on what i call the real
working people
and then a magic thing happened
we changed the laws we decided to hold
them accountable and governor it was a
democrat governor that signed the
legislation that started us down the
path originally to make a positive
difference
now i look around the country today
i've seen a few things
i was recently the president of the
major county sheriffs of america
i talked to
and counseled with
the sheriffs from the largest
jurisdictions in the entire nation
to include the los angeles sheriff's
office in fact the the sheriff there was
my vice president of the association at
one time
and you know what they tell me
they tell me we got a dumpster fire
going on in this nightmare is that one
of you guys and you know who's getting
burned by this dumpster fire dumpster
for the working people yeah it's him you
know it's not painters on the phone
here's my dreamers it can't be ready for
the mentally ill aren't being looked out
for and it's by the major people now
governor i know you'd be disappointed if
you didn't see some cards
what's the friar's club give you a
snapshot of the people that join
prosecutor warren and not enforce them
racist jokes about sammy by the way
shouldn't he refer to him as former
state prosecutor warren
that's a good good point
that would have been donald trump oh i'm
oh i'm sorry
[Laughter]
it looks photoshopped
because they weren't holding criminals
accountable
chicago i think that speaks for itself
los angeles
where the sheriff told me i've got 60
000 homeless
wow
we have criminals running wild
we have innocent people being victimized
and who's responsible there
the prosecutor the chief prosecutor
who's allowing it to occur
he has the law he has the tools
baltimore maryland
but that's not all
then there's one of our favorite places
portland oregon
you can set up a chop zone there did you
hear the audience not let the cops come
in
[Laughter]
as long as it takes me to drive back
there from here
they got the guy from death comedy yeah
is it coming from new york yeah
where they're not
it comes out with the hook seattle
washington
and washington dc
so what's the commonality here democrats
just go look for yourself
look at the data the murders are up
innocent people are being murdered where
prosecutors don't do their job
my friend chad chronister just gave you
an example
we don't have time to stand here all day
but listen
prosecutor warren
like the rest of us who ran for public
office
we asked for your precious vote
in order to enforce the law and do what
was right
then we took an oath to tell the truth
to uphold the constitution
and to support the laws in the
government
and we do that
and we're led by the greatest government
kind of language
could not hear
at a democrat rally right now
it wouldn't land can't say law you can't
say rule of law constitution it's not
something that is permissible
but there are signs a city of people not
being gunned down
couldn't really i mean sad sign the
papers
that said they wouldn't prosecute
not we'll evaluate it case by case we
won't prosecute
you know
they're not god
they're not the legislature
so at the end of the day ladies and
gentlemen this is about protecting the
community we serve
this is about keeping people safe
and when you look at the highest murder
rates
when you look where the quality of life
is lowest
you look at the prosecutor who does not
support law enforcement who does not do
what's right
our governor does what's right
and governor i appreciate from the
bottom of my heart
you setting the example
and doing the right thing
and keeping the people safe
and the exciting thing is you not only
protect the people behind the gated
communities
you pro you protect the people who clean
the gates on those communities thank you
god bless you
pretty strong also this shows you that
conservatives understand that the
importance of municipal government yeah
using cities as examples the left always
says look at the poorest states uh most
of them are red sure
they don't have the same kind of crime
infestations that you're talking so this
is a problem the left always says
poverty is a problem poverty isn't the
problem
poverty itself isn't the problem and
certainly not the wealth gap the problem
is the ramifications of certain
poverty-stricken neighborhoods largely
run by democrat mayors places like
detroit yeah sure some of them have drug
problems they don't have the violent
crime problem he just pointed to cities
you have states that are petri dishes
and then you have cities which are also
little experiments and he was just
pointing to tampa in florida it was an
outlier
so let's go back to uh governor ron
desantis
the men and women of the agencies
to protect our community
and then to turn around and find out
those cases got fought no filed right to
find out that they have to go back to a
victim and say sorry this won't be
prosecuted
those are very difficult
there's no way they're going to cover
this so we need to make sure we have a
backup of this they'll cover it later
when they have the angle oh they'll
basically just call ron desantis a bully
yeah they'll call him a fascist and the
quiet girl who gets loud from police
academy yeah yes
it'll be totally fine a couple of stats
on warren if you want them uh sure let's
do that so some of the reasons that he
has been kicked out uh or basically
being suspended from office suspended
kicked out sounds better it just sounds
less ceremonious yeah so basically he
said that there were seven thousand one
of his crowning achievements is seven
thousand people that had uh i think they
were driving without an id or driving
without identification uh is one of
those things that he just said we aren't
going to to do anything with that right
and so there were some ramifications to
that that wasn't the major thing though
his recent comment that i think really
sent it over the edge was he is not
going to prosecute doctors or anybody
else who gets an abortion
right under the new laws that they're
saying he's just basically anybody else
who performs in a book and performs an
abortion he's not he's saying i am not
going to enforce the laws of the state
of florida i'm going to kind of do
whatever i want to do and desantis just
fired a shot across the bow for every
single prosecutor in that state yeah you
enforce the rules that we the people
signed by electing representatives who
put forward bills that came across my
desk and i signed them otherwise you
don't have a job yeah no i think that's
a good point you know what uh instead of
going to the uh clips of ron and send us
we're gonna mix it up a little bit we'll
go to this we can bite after i make this
point
um because i think it's an important
contrast here's what the left is going
to do this is what i'm this is what i
was saying you can call me on this they
are going to try and point to this
just like it did with disney
and say ron desantis is using the law as
a fascist you guys don't have a problem
when they do it and then you accuse by
insert whatever it is here
actual fascist action that was
undertaken by the president you know
like locking down economies like
punishing like saying that he would
override states rights on certain issues
right this is something that they will
do they will try and make it seem as
though ron desantis is a fascist let's
be really clear here what ron desantis
is doing and what i like about ron
decent is governor on desantis and don't
get me wrong
very much like and appreciate donald
trump vote for any one of them if they
are in the general
governor ron desantis has been working
on this for a while
he made the announcement once he aimed
and aimed correctly one shot boom that's
what he does he does it well he still
makes sure to put the media on their
heels and we have clips from what he did
yesterday he still makes sure to keep
fighting the front as fighting on the
fronts that are occurring right now but
he is working behind the scenes and when
he comes out with something whether it's
the disney um the disney was it a bill
exactly or was it just that we're just
going to revoke your tax against yeah
just revoking broke your tax benefits so
i didn't even at that point i don't even
think it needed to be a bill i think
technically yeah not renewing there you
go um
he did it behind the scenes
made sure that he was right made sure
that he had the authority to do so did
it and then the left says that he was a
fascist so let's compare uh what
governor desantis is doing and i
guarantee you they will try and say this
is a man using government uh as a as a a
hammer is what they're going to try and
say he's simply demanding that people
who are elected
represent the people who elect them and
the laws of that state
if you're going to ask me i think that
that state prosecutor that state
attorney attorney
it's not the attorney general it's not
the training general andrew murray
think he's a fascist if he says wait a
second there's a law here in florida
that we have was passed by the state
legislature and we have a system of
checks and balances i'm not going to
enforce it
what did i say
murray oh murray no not andrew murray
who's andrew murray i don't know
i know douglas murray is you know very a
wonderful friend to be honest i'm just
still stuck on the driver's license part
isn't that the first red flag to
continue the procedure right yeah just
don't go oh no license yeah my bad guess
we can't hold you uh to anything yeah
he's like hey i don't know who you are
uh voting booth's over there all right
he basically came in and said hey we i
cleared out like 30 percent of our
backlog oh that's fantastic work for me
on the job how'd you do that we just
didn't prosecute right because we all
know how democrats love clearing up red
tape
so no to me it's far more fascist to not
enforce the laws that were decided upon
either by your actual constituents the
voters or your state legislature
depending on what kind of a bill uh
depending on the bill that we're looking
at let's go now to speaking of abortion
and rape and uh gross overreach of the
federal government let's go to this week
invite wait if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're for me or
trump then you ain't black all right uh
let me make sure i have this here uh
what is this is oh another executive
order yeah this is an executive order
from joe biden okay tuesday
sorry i'm we're mixing and mixing
everything up here today because this
stuff is going live
and it secures funding for interstate
abortion
tourism
a tragic case of rape survivors
including a 10 year old girl forced to
travel another state for care you know
wiping out the right to choose on them
whether you have a
incest abortion excuse me incest or uh
having uh a stutter because it runs in
the family this is just extreme
you know even the life of the mother
in some cases i'll stop there and turn
this over to the vice president there's
so much more to say but i'm anxious to
hear from all of you
thank you thank you thank you do i sign
this order now
i'm going to sign this executive order
that's a menu sir
it says denny's
[Laughter]
so okay
yes it's hysterical but terrible
and yes it's hysterical now
uh think of this for saying there are a
couple things that are wrong with that
you talk about a ten-year-old yeah
having to travel for abortion
both states he was talking about have
rape exceptions yeah they do
so okay what's the reason for this
executive order both states have an
exemption uh or exceptions for rape so
what he's talking about now is medicaid
will be used to reimburse travel for
abortions remember safe legal and rare i
talked about this yesterday i said it's
not only no longer safe legal and rare
it's not only just shout your abortion
it's taxpayers you need to be on the
hook to fund the uber
for people to cross state lines and get
abortions come on now we're way beyond
common ground tell me that that isn't
fascist ron desantis wants to get rid of
a a corrupt prosecutor for not i don't
know prosecuting crimes as they listed
joe biden wants to make sure
that even though of course the judicial
branch is supposed to be entirely
separate and states have the right to
decide their own abortion laws that he
is going to override it and force you
the taxpayer at a federal level to fund
abortion tourism predicated on a lie
because that ten-year-old
would already have an exception yeah
would have already been able to get the
care that she needed in that situation
right i understand it but why don't we
talk about i don't understand it i'm not
entirely sure that it's a true story i i
know there was a whole lot of
speculation about it um but really what
they they didn't cover was okay well yes
that is a terrible situation she she
could have gotten the care that she
wanted in either state
who raped her
why didn't we why aren't we talking
about the rapist oh you mean like the
kids who had monkey pox in the uh
household yeah they arrested a guy they
did they arrested a guy for doing it i
believe he was here illegally in the
country and somewhere in ohio never made
he was pulled over but he didn't have id
so either yeah let him go yeah keep
going that's the thing
nobody wants to talk
you made the point just a second ago
right that we were talking about
symptoms and we're not treating the root
cause the root cause of what happened
here is that somebody did something
illegal that will forever change this
girl's life from 10 years old i cannot
imagine if i was that father i would not
want to see a justice system that didn't
involve me and a shotgun right at the
very end of it right of course i can't
imagine because we don't enforce our
laws
that's what happened the person should
never have been here in the first place
look catch and release is the exact same
problem as not having a wall not having
the border yeah it's it's it's the exact
same problem why even why release well
because they could hurt so they could
hurt somebody that's why i'm against
releasing these hardened criminals or
why do you want a wall because they can
hurt people and there'd be no way of
tracking it
one guy in new york that was released
robbed the same store i think 27 times
let me ask you this let me walk through
a logic
yes
everything that you say here can be
admitted into court oh
sorry fred is screwed how many how many
uh people do this andrew uh andrew uh
warren this prosecutor how many did you
brag about letting go without id drivers
the seven thousand okay seven thousand
we said that's not the big deal but it
actually is a big deal let me ask you
this let's go through this question okay
serious think about this if someone
doesn't have an ident uh identification
at all no form of identification okay
ask yourself this they're driving with
no form of identification right and keep
in mind police are often even if you
don't have a driver's license they don't
stop there like well okay they'll ask
for any form of identification and then
of course they'll usually cite you for
driving without a license
um
if someone is driving and doesn't have a
driver's license do you think that that
makes them significantly more
or even just a little less likely
to be committing a crime
now
put that in your back pocket
let's continue okay let's say that they
are more likely to commit a crime let's
say that they're just as likely the same
likelihood of committing a crime as
somebody who doesn't have any form of id
like most citizens um
do you think that they are more or less
likely to be caught
and to be held accountable
there's a reason for it there's a reason
that you need a driver's license there's
a and i understand libertarians i
understand that cops can't just ask you
willy-nilly for id but they can if you
are breaking the law in a car and you
are driving without a license if you're
driving with a suspended license
one time i got just my lice that was
down the street and i didn't have my
license on me i said well here you go
and i think i had my uh
some kind of a paper i don't know i
think i think i had a digital copy i
don't know exactly what it was oh i had
a picture on my phone but even then he
was like you know this really shouldn't
count
but i'll give you a warning the point is
i would have accepted the ticket and say
i screwed up
so think about more less likely to
commit a crime if they don't have
identification and let's assume that you
don't believe people who are likely here
illegally if they have no form of
invocation let's assume that you don't
believe i don't know every statistic
that we've seen in relation to illegal
immigrants and their increased
likelihood for crime not immigrants
illegal immigrants undocumented
immigrants let's assume you don't
believe that you still have to accept
that there would be no way to enforce
the law do you think do you think if you
go through those 7 000 people in florida
you think you might find a rapist
and by the way warren called it his
proudest achievement yeah um
i and he can pee standing up
[Laughter]
no way he must be so proud that you're
saying i mean i'm exaggerating he
he maybe does a squat yeah exactly so
forward squat we're seeing it right now
we're seeing this exactly the left goes
this is horrible we want to look we we
need to
we need to usurp your rights here by
signing an executive order because
you're in danger okay what are you doing
to stop the danger biden
new york portland seattle los angeles
they just mentioned tampa they are right
now
taking steps in florida to prevent more
extreme examples that you use to make
your case like 10 year olds being raped
because of prosecutors not upholding the
law how many people do you think were
raped how many people do you think were
murdered how many people do you think
were mugged how many being bn's do you
think there were how many how many acts
of arson from people who were released
because of leftist prosecutors or
defunding the police or catch and
release as we've covered in graphic
detail in places like new york city all
references available at ladderscript.com
this is where they try and gaslight you
and say that you're being conspiratorial
when you see that it's by design of
course the left wants there to be more
crime
of course the left wants there to be
more pandemics because that's the only
way that they can control you i'm not
saying that they're secretly committing
crimes themselves although this
prosecutor probably i'm not saying that
they're secretly engineering diseases
but what i am saying is they have a
vested interest in keeping you afraid
and keeping you poor i've talked about
this repeatedly the only way that
governor desantis does well in election
and if you want to disagree with a
comment below i would love to hear an
argument against this
i i can't imagine one the only way
governor ron desantis wins
is if people are optimistic
if people believe that they are going to
be that they have the potential to be
better off if people believe that there
will be less crime if people believe
that they will be less at risk for
diseases that's the that's the only way
he wins
the only way he wins is by making you
more successful otherwise he
wouldn't he couldn't possibly win that's
his platform the only way a democrat
wins is by telling you that you need
them because you need to be afraid and
they need to come in and ensure that
they can protect you from the
skyrocketing crime that they can protect
you from the scary diseases they need
you to be afraid if they are the party
of the poor
they need you to be poor
you need to understand just look at what
is required for governor desantis to win
versus is it uh nikki freed oh well
who's who's held fried
anyway that's been this week in biden
okay wait if you have a problem figuring
out whether you're for me or trump and
you ain't black really quickly speaking
of this uh uh speaking of voting um
robert hughes 58 a man in ohio was
arrested i don't even saw this tuesday
after threatening to shoot
a voting machine oh wow which i would
say is extreme he was charged with
inducing panic threatening violence
which is a second degree felony and that
now lawyers are saying he could actually
be facing additional charges for a hate
crime as the voting machine was black
so that's okay okay yeah that's
you can't do that
yeah it's some hard times we need a
pallet cleanse
uh do we want to
show uh any of the ronda santa claus it
seems like they're kind of irrelevant at
this point well i mean he was talking
about some different stuff and he's you
know he kind of dovetails into what he's
doing here he's he's taking the steps
that governors across the country need
to be taking he's basically standing up
and saying okay that's enough enough of
this liberalism enough progressivism
here just enforce the laws just make
sure that you know we're getting
students
taken care of imagine being a person who
thinks it's a good thing to not
to not enforce identification laws and
drivers well it's just it's happening
everywhere in these democrat cities like
not enforcing the laws of san francisco
this is good i feel good about this
decision yeah it just doesn't make any
sense to pull somebody over and go well
i guess we can't go anywhere from here
i don't know who the heck you are no id
ah have a good night sir that'd be a
horrible film noir
is there any idea for the girl tied up
in the back no
rats sorry sweetheart
hands are tied good luck yours too i
just think it's disgusting too to just
like use this 10 year old girl which
should be a completely private situation
and can be taken care of
it's just it's it's gross yeah and
yeah
it's it's everything about it yeah and
then he's like oh we need so now we all
get to pay for uh we'll get to pay for
what's the the other uber one what's the
other one not uber what's the other one
lift lift yeah you'll get to pay for the
lifts
the lifts for ladies straight into the
stirrups now there's a new one called
cradle yeah
it's awesome
[Laughter]
i can't i can't make it to the state
line i'm too sad to get an abortion oh
man i'll just phrase it wrong
[Laughter]
i want to see desantis and i want to see
other state lawmakers
standing up and doing this other
governors if they're going to sign an
executive order that basically says no
matter what the state of texas decides
no matter what its citizens come
together and decide about abortion which
is now not a federal issue but a state
issue
we're not giving you money for that if
you guys use our money in a way that we
are not in agreement with and it's not
just saying i pick and choose what you
pay taxes on i'm not saying that you're
you're deliberately going against what
the supreme court has said is now a
state issue by trying to find a loophole
for it so legislatures you guys need to
stand up and say this and then in
washington people like ted cruz if he's
gonna do this you guys need to pass some
bills that say no no no no you can't use
federal money that comes from states
that have abortion laws in place to fund
abortions for their citizens to travel
out of state and basically just find a
loophole for it you can't do that they
did it with uh planned parenthood where
they're like oh
service money not abortion do you think
that at a certain point the left is
trying to goad people into some kind of
a civil conflict
think about a certain point where it's
like okay look roe v wade was bad law
okay then the court which is supposed to
be separate said this is going to go
back to the states the state said okay
we're going to create this is what we're
going to create as a law in our state
and then the
commander-in-chief
says no instead i'm going to override it
along with locking down states think
about a certain point people in their
state who have the right to make
decisions for their state feel
absolutely powerless were they no long
where they can no longer say well you
know what that's the beauty of states
rights this government is ensuring that
you know
your state doesn't have
rights
it looks like desantis is back up
speaking not just introducing people
okay all right let's see what he has to
say attorney
is to apply the law and enforce the law
not pick and choose which laws you like
and which laws you don't like okay judge
come on up
[Laughter]
what judgment is the new like uh while
the other judge is suspended no the
state attorney no it's a judge this is a
judge but oh it's a judge attorney was a
keep in mind i'm looking at a small
screen here so okay
thank you thank you
good morning and thank you for being
here today
i want to first thank governor desantis
for placing his trust in me
to execute the duties of state attorney
of the 13th judicial circuit and by the
way he's your replacement i told you i'm
sorry i thought you said he was a judge
as well well that state attorney yes
yeah
now she's the state attorney yeah
which has been a judge can be a state
attorney just like an attorney can
become a judge well you're not going to
hold both a woman
i'm not i'm not wild about it either
[Laughter]
i hold the utmost respect for our state
laws and i understand the important role
that the state attorney plays in
ensuring the safety of our community can
you imagine the morning that andrew ward
is having right now i'm sorry he said
what i'm suspended oh we'll fight that
don't worry he's like a replacement
already like sitting on a smart they're
like
they're like sawing the name off of his
head
[Laughter]
they didn't tell him they just had this
news conference exactly yeah
they pushed his name card out of the
office like a scrabble board just yeah
governor desantis it's best to do this
on friday at five nope uh thursday nine
a.m sharp actually make it 9 10 that way
he's already in his seat when it happens
i knew i should have let seven thousand
and one people go
get my job i love it the state attorney
has his gavel and it's just pulled out
of his hand like a candy cane from the
grinch just yet
[Laughter]
guess what guys
[Laughter]
bring in a miami 3.
[Laughter]
you judge are now a state attorney
but we're a one-piece you're in florida
[Laughter]
all right so let's go to some of the
things that he said yesterday so you can
now see some foreshadowing he started
throwing haymakers yesterday ron
desantis and uh it was kind of a teaser
of what was to come love it his first
target was again
true heroes true not teachers at this
point the other true heroes public
health officials this was yesterday
governor ron desantis they would shame
people for even leaving their house in
april may 2020
and you can't do it some people wanted
to bury loved ones they wanted to do
this and the argument people were making
is well wait a minute i can look at the
risk of covid and it's something that
i'm willing to accept because these
things mean more to me to be able to
bury a loved one or to be able to do
things with my family and in the public
health
establish oh no no you can't make that
kind of cost benefit analysis then
when the george floyd riots were
happening
they actually wrote a letter with
thousands of these people signing it
saying
we do not believe
that rioting and protesting
is a is
bad for kovid that you can do it go
ahead because we think it's so important
that you have to do it and then they
said but this doesn't mean we support
all protests of course if you're
protesting
lockdown policies or other things then
you can't do that and that's when i knew
these people are a bunch of frauds i
mean how ridiculous
that's right
it's put pretty well not a whole lot to
disagree with there oh no that was
fantastic i couldn't believe it when it
was actually happening i'm like they're
gonna this this is fine and that's not
yeah we were covering it live huh well
you risk all kinds of things doing
anything if that's the risk you're
willing to take to go bury a loved one
or be part of something that's a deal
not as risky to burn a cop car though no
no no no no no fire keeps covered away
loot a lucky brand store now uh
sorry
sneakers got so many great jeans
i got some new kicks you like these
george floyd would have wanted it this
way now
saint his next step that's true
gender affirming doctors governor
desantis
that was his next target let's play it
involved in just protecting children in
this state across a wide variety of
things and one of the things that
they're trying to do
is they talk about these very young kids
getting
gender affirming care they don't tell
you what that is is they're actually
giving very young girls double
mastectomies they want to castrate these
young boys that's wrong and so we've
stood up and said both from the health
and children well-being perspective you
know you don't disfigure
10 12 13 year old kids uh based on
gender dysphoria by the way he just said
something that would have gotten us
yeah good
i love it
all right i guess uh right now he's
taking questions governor desantis okay
this is happening live and by the way
hit the like button if you want more of
this as we uh cover events live as they
unfold i just sort of fell in our lap
here this morning
one that was making those types of
declarations he was the only one signing
his name to letters that basically said
to hell with the people of florida i'm
going to do what i want you know we take
care that the laws are faithfully
executed not every law on the books in
florida do i agree with i mean it is
what it is
and yes there are sometimes the
legislature will put laws on my desk
that i veto and then it doesn't become
law that's called a retail they haven't
done that yet uh and so uh but that's
just the way the system works i never
get my fake dick now quite right i'm
uncommitted
overwrote it uh i don't think that will
happen but if it did then i would be
duty-bound to to enforce that law i
can't just say you know what and throw a
hissy fit and say oh i don't think it's
good and i'm not going to enforce that's
not the way uh the law works and so that
it in if you look around the country the
root of a lot of the problems is that
this idea has taken hold
that you can be a law unto yourself
doesn't really matter what the
legislature does if you believe that
that's a little hot compared to the
conflicts with your idiosyncratic vision
of quote social justice then that gives
you veto authority and that is not how a
constitutional system can operate that
is not how a rule of law can operate and
ultimately you know you cannot have safe
and strong communities
if we're not having enforcement of the
law
but what was it that led to you to
ultimately make this decision was it his
signing that letter regarding
thank you for the question he's a piece
of [ __ ] next well so as i said you are
fake
problems around the country were coming
to a head i asked my office earlier this
year to to do a survey of what what's
going on in florida to see because
there's there's how do you do a survey
when people don't have id
on a sheet of paper i'm not prosecuting
i'm going to ignore i mean that's a
that's a very egregious thing to do but
you will have sometimes policies which
are de facto
nullifications of the law so they will
say well you may be able to prosecute
but in circumstances that would never
happen so require them to go and do a
lot a lot of different things but yes
when you have the
2021 letter saying no matter what the
state of no matter what a state declares
about protecting child welfare with
respect i mean you know they use these
euphemisms but what it is is they are
literally
chopping off the private parts of young
kids
that's wrong and you know we're doing
stuff administratively and with medical
licenses but you know the legitimacy
only happens
some instances they sew up your vagina
with stitches like a helena bonham
carter uh character ah some of the best
things that have been in place and then
after dobbs comes down where the supreme
court said this is returned to the
states to say that the the laws that we
have you're just not gonna enforce any
of them and he drew no distinction i
mean we've always had prohibition on
third trimester abortion we've always
had prohibition or at least for a while
on partial birth and now the three and a
half months it's okay that was a
legislative debate there were some
people that had different views on it
the legislature passed it i signed it so
that's what you have to do so those are
really i think egregious and again it's
beyond just exercising discretion
whereas discretion would be i may get an
individual case and make a determination
you know that we're not going to go with
prosecution because you have limited
resources what have you uh where where
it goes across the line is where that
ends up being used to effectively you
guys can comment below
thank you you're watching the makings
[Music]
but i think
that if you do your part
and we do our part you know and and by
the way i'm not in the business of
endorsing candidates what i can do is
show you what it is that they are saying
and you can make up your mind you can
endorse your local candidates but if we
do our part and make sure that you know
what the act of politicians who are
actually
fighting for you
uh what they're saying and you go out
and make sure that people you know you
know you pay it forward in a way that
pisses off all the right people uh i
think
this can be his coming out party for a
lot of people i think most people know i
think republicans know but i think this
is something that you know what i'm i'm
trying to think
trying to see this through the eyes of
let's say the latino voters who are
becoming more conservative the black
voters on the trans issues who are
incredibly conservative everyone but
suburban white [ __ ] this is something
no one can disagree with
it just that's why they're not covering
it on cnn see it's the 19th aarp
commercial yeah they've been on long
commercials yeah they've been a long
commercials talking about uh reiner in
russia
griner griner oh sorry teddy reiner is a
french judoka who's a monster by the way
but yeah griner robert
grimey as she like to be called let's uh
cry me let's go to desantis again an
election site but wherever they're
putting in a ballot needs to be
monitored uh by an election official all
the whole time absolutely god forbid we
have secure elections just sitting there
with no monitoring you know that
obviously is inconsistent with the law
so we have in place the ability to uh
to investigate this
people driving vehicles should
have driver's licenses
voting voting stations should have
monitoring what oh my gosh you it's the
third rank yes saying it should take
some kind of test to drive this
automobile and have proof of it hmm i
don't think so
people don't even know seven thousand
friends well you're an outside the box
thinker i'll give you that but that's
not for us
we believe you count the votes and you
should go on elections
is this your 92 ford taurus some of
these other states do it so uh
do you hear what he said he's like we
just i think you you know you cast the
vote you count the votes you declare a
winner on election night we're one of
the biggest states we can do it
yeah you know not exactly florida's had
some uh
well they had the hanging they had some
missteps well that was a long time ago
they're talking about now i know let's
go back to time
today i mean you yes you can get elected
to county-wide office but when you take
office you swear to uphold the laws and
constitution of the state of florida and
so if you're not doing that well then
that's something we need to have
accountability and recourse for so okay
well thanks everybody we appreciate
seeing you
i got some more butts to kick i'll be
back it's very jolly ending yeah yeah
hey thanks joe
thank you seeing
how much you want to bet uh there's
someone in that lineup who's handy shook
and uh he told them to go screw
themselves
i think that's so he just has the same
kind of personality as donald trump with
that he's got a little bit like of a
prick in him and he's gonna go after
people he really just doesn't care yeah
uh but he's more polished in some ways
meaning he's been in the political
system a little bit longer it doesn't
mean he's gonna do a better job trump
was absolutely the guy we needed at the
time and i'm not saying he would be a
bad candidate i just think desantis has
less baggage right now look here with
the same spirit here's what i i think
it's just going to be too much blowback
with trump i mean if you want me to be
honest i and i think this guy's
a little bit more poised here's the only
thing that i will say i will be very
pissed if this happens okay
if it's ron desantis if it's donald
trump
i will vote for this person if it's
someone else right who's a decent
republican i will vote for that person
it's not my job to try and tell you who
to vote for in the primary you know
where i line up in a general election if
you're a person of principle you are
today precluded from voting for a
democrat
that being said
and by the way both governor desantis uh
donald uh former president donald trump
you are uh welcome to come on the show
and we've had donald trump junior in the
show friend of the show yeah uh has
always been a great guy so
i just don't want to see donald trump go
dirty on ron desantis because if donald
trump is losing the primary we don't
know he may win the primary
don't try and kneecap him and ruin it
for the rest of us and burn this whole
thing down if donald trump does that
then
we're going to have some problems
and i just don't want to see the people
who are the cultists of donald trump
burn the rest of it down i get it ron
desantis isn't perfect neither is donald
trump we can go back and forth on that
either one of them not only would be
better than biden that's a very very low
bar to clear
it would be entirely suitable president
yeah
well and think about this it's a
four-year term right so he's already
he's already had one he can only do one
more he would have four years so if he
does end up beating desantis we need
desantis strong and ready to come out
exactly 28 right so you don't want to
put him in a position i mean assuming he
wants to and i'm assuming he would
and let's be honest we're all more
concerned about donald trump taking a
steaming crap on desantis that's
unwarranted then the santa's doing it
without trump i just really hope that
doesn't happen
by the monkey wrench that donald trump
was into a system that i didn't even
realize was this corrupt and that's not
anything against donald trump it's just
they've already showed their hand in how
bad they're willing to make it right and
i don't think they can pull the same
crap with the santas as they can with
trump that's why if trump attacks them
it's extremely negative they will pull
the scene but they have to start from
scratch absolutely yeah right that's
what donald trump they say well we
already know we've already had two
impeachments yeah but with ron desantis
they'll try and look they tried they did
it with george w bush
uh they did it with ronald reagan to a
degree it was a little more civil but
not really yeah
you can kind of say that george bush
senior and clinton
both of because they were both pretty
much centrists you know at best
that being said they're going to do this
to anybody we don't need to do their job
for them and i just hope that president
trump doesn't let ego get in the way if
he sees that this is slipping away from
him and desantis is winning not saying
that that is what's going to happen
donald trump could win a poll by a
landslide and could be the nominee
tomorrow and i would vote for him with a
smile yeah i just don't want to say well
actually he sucks like he did with you
know
everyone
[Music]
small handsome sometimes it's warranted
yeah well funny people are getting when
you're like well there's no way he's
going to win and then you're like oh my
goodness right like yeah you're getting
so far you're going to fall off the
stage so far to the left now
like low energy jeb that'll never catch
on no please clap
oh my god he's a male 1 i've ever seen
in politics uh all right so
i guess we can we can move on but you
guys let me know what you think below
cause last time it was 50 50 desantis
trump when we asked this question yeah
we're already already about an hour in
too i know i know can we do sweden
uh swedish
yeah i mean we could probably go through
that pretty quickly okay i don't think
that'll take too long by the way
brittany griner has been convicted of uh
of uh doing it with the criminal intent
uh so committed she committed a crime
deliberately drug smuggling drug
spending i think it was a vape pen yeah
maybe it was a little well you know what
though the truth is for those of you out
there who don't necessarily know this
you do have to be careful you know vape
pens are concentrates so they don't do
that by the same laws as you know they
say a certain amount ounces or grams of
loose flour a vape pen is basically
equivalent to a metric ton as far as how
some states measure wow and in russia it
doesn't matter no they'll just i wonder
if this is a negotiation play though
because i know right now they're trying
to get back some arms traffickers you
know people who are responsible for the
deaths of thousands of people around the
world i'm assuming um all of whom had id
yeah
so brittany grinder like sentence her to
some you know real gaudy
50 years or something like that so that
they can increase the uh
the number of people that they get
because we're holding people they want
and i don't know that we really want
britney grinder back i'm not saying this
like of course we're just like
you don't speak for the three members of
her fan club i don't you're right i'm
not saying she's a bad person i'm just
saying i mean like i don't know she has
fewer fans in the washington wizards
[Laughter]
that's just not true
you know what it absolutely is yeah no i
guarantee you there is oh yeah
for those who are going what for those
of the women who are watching i don't
know what he's referencing the team that
exclusively lose to the harlem
globetrotters they have more fans than
brittany griner but of course i really
do hope that she comes back and she gets
i do but look this is also really really
really dumb i'm sorry this goes to the
entitlement mindset of someone who
thinks well i have the right to do this
no you don't you don't have the right to
you didn't know that hash oil was gonna
be a problem in russia and by the way he
didn't think they were gonna pat you
down as a black american i'm telling you
it's terrible i can't stand that russia
did it don't like russia what was she
doing there anyway do we know i know she
wasn't beating their basketball teams
i really don't have an idea i think she
was playing like freelance in russia oh
what's your name
yeah yeah because they pay more for
female athletes in russia they can't pay
the bills on her
nba i know it's it's a mistake and it's
a crime but
i don't think she's being jailed for
that no i mean she should come home but
it's it's going to be a prisoner swap
kind of thing and they're just i don't
know they think there's a hell of a swap
for a vape pen
yeah this guy who sold you know i don't
know kalishnikovs to uh africa for 20
years yeah and uh we what'd she do well
she brought a vape in here's your hand a
short table
no long time i don't know i'd maybe swap
yak off smear enough i'd consider it
well yeah i mean there's people we i
mean can we pick the swap yeah can we
pick the swap that's like i think we
have a new i think we have a new state
attorney who's going to be available
yeah yeah we could
you guys want this guy yeah just have
him walk out in the cool hand luke
shackles take him he loves me
uh hey speaking of which by the way yes
there is a little bit of a problem with
monkey pox in miami there is is there
now
um
that's a [ __ ] that's a segue so uh we
actually we've talked about this on air
and some people have gotten mad at us uh
saying that you're misrepresenting
monkey pox and so we actually uh
there's a psa that we've put together to
help you
so that this doesn't reach the levels of
the next pandemic
or a pandemic you know that's what i
heard yeah it's pandemic uh here's how
you can protect yourself from monkeybox
[Music]
hey there billy
what's wrong billy boy
say you're not worried about that monkey
fox virus going around now are you
oh billy
well monkey parks is serious and
sometimes can be fatal the good news is
that you can take simple steps to
protect yourself against this silly
disease here are the first steps to take
to protect you
step one
avoid engaging in unprotected sodomy
with strange men
[Applause]
congratulations billy you are now fully
protected against monkey pox it's as
easy as one
now you know all the ways to avoid
monkey fox
looking good billy
looking good
brought to you by mug club for a better
society sign up today at
loudouthrider.com for only 99 annually
69 for students veterans or active
military or visit louder with carter.com
monkeypops mug club making a better
world and a monkey fox3u
but it never be said that we didn't do
anything good
by the way before we uh go to uh we're
gonna have to do a sweden thing on mug
club because we're just not gonna have
time uh walter official sponsor of uh
well actually the official protection of
the lateral crowder studios you know i
don't really do a whole lot of libraries
you can't go to waltherarms.com and
purchase the firearm you can go to a
shop or you can go to your local gun
range and try them this is the pdp it
has this like this super slide serration
and this unbelievable trigger look this
is all i ask that you do go try it run a
google search right now or bing
duckduckgo you can ask jeeves
pdp review
type in walther ppq review type in
walther pps review any walth or gun type
in review and you'll see that's the best
kept secret in the firearm industry and
the balls to sponsor this show cannot
say enough good things about them uh
what do we need to tell people share the
show
i don't know dave's gonna be in the
funny bone in uh funny bone dayton ohio
this week i almost said columbus again i
know it was it was just there i was
thinking of the knights of yes tickets
just went on so for october
first in uh michigan you can check it
out daveland.com but yeah i'm gonna be
in dayton columbus don't go to columbus
oh wait hold on a second before we leave
before we leave yes
you noticed gerald's little quip earlier
was it about my mustache no no when we
first came into the show yeah you got a
douchebag shirt on what do you want
whoa
so interesting you should say that
do we have we actually have
and
just so people in case and you can
comment below if you want to make sure
because gerald does this stuff all the
time ah and it grinds my gears this
whole nice guy it's an act
it's absolutely an act really yeah
it's okay
it's 50 shades of [ __ ] okay with you
it's just constant it's constant the
second we the second we stopped the show
you can't look him in the face no he
comes furniture i know well that was a
trend it wasn't it's true we did ask you
like torn levi's for you or i just
football for you well they don't start
torn now
gerald is
my show uh my show crapping on my shirt
well yeah we have security camera
footage of the shirt that you wore when
you came in here today let's show this
shirt
do we have the
for the footage yeah bring it up bring
it up
[Music]
right here what's the matter with the
shirt it's the trans flag it's guys i'm
gay it's not the transfer that is the
trans flag this is your shirt that is
this is your shirt
how dare you make sure you don't look at
me when the show's over magnum pi yeah
magnum pi that's a great shape shirt
[Music]
magnum pi chas bono feel that shirt
though
that shirt says it is nice
[Laughter]
i'd suture up my snatch if i got to wear
one of those all right
youtube piss off
[Music]
you